استقبل رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
عبد الحميد دبيبه في طرابلس مديره
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه وليام
بيرز في اول زياره لمسؤولا رفيع في اداره
بايدا الى ليبيا وكانت وسائل الاعلام
الليبيه اكدت ان بيرز التقى في بنغازي
اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر من جانبها
حذرت الامم المتحده من ان تاخير التواصل
الى حل في ليبيا قد يؤدي الى تقسيمها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبرتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله ارسال واشنطن مسؤول
الامنيا الى ليبيا في هذا التوقيت وما
الاعتبارات التي حدد على اساسها مضيفيه من
اطراف المشهد السياسي الليبي وما هي
الاجنده التي حملها مدير الاستخبارات
الامريكيه في زيارته الى طرابلس وبنغازي
وما هي الاولويات الامريكيه في ليبيا في
هذه المرحله
وما الدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه واشنطن في
حل الازمه الليبيه في ظل تاكيد اداراه
اهتمامها بليبيا وتحذير الامم المتحده من
امكانيه تفكك البلاد في حال تاخر الحمل
[موسيقى]
في بيان نشرته على صفحتها بموقع الفيسبوك
قالت حكومه الوحده الوطنيه ليبيه ان
رئيسها عبد الحميد استقبل في طرابلس يوم
الخميس مديره وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه ويليامبرز اللقاء الذي غاب عنه
سفير واشنطن ومبعوثها الخاص الى ليبيا
ريتشارد نور لاند اكد فيه بيرز بحسب حكومه
الوحده ضروره تطوير التعاون الاقتصادي
والامني بين البلدين وقد شملت زياره بارز
الى ليبيا لقائه اللواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر في بنغازي بحسب وسائل الاعلام ليبيه
لم تذكر اي تفاصيل بشان اجنده اللقاء فيه
[موسيقى]
في مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الثاني المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى ليبيا
ومن اسطنبول السنوسي بسيكريه مدير المركز
الليبي للبحوث والتنميه مرحبا بكما سيد
وينر ابدا معك لماذا اختارت واشنطن ارسال
الشخصيه امنيه لزياره ليبيا في هذا
التوقيت وليس مثلا شخصيه من الخارجيه
الامريكيه
او ثلاثه حيث يمكن
له اهميه في المشاركه اولها مجال التعاون
في مكافحه الارهاب ولو كان هناك تهديد
ارهابي يحتاج الى التصدي له وتطلب وتعاونا
امنيا بين الولايات المتحده على اعلى
المستويات ايضا هناك استمرار الوجود
الروسي في ليبيا ونشاطات مجموعه
نار
خارجيه داخل الدائره المقربه من الرئيس
مازن يعتبر الشخصيه الاهم بخبرته الواسعه
وايت رسائل سيحملها ستكون رسائل موافقه
عليها على اعلى مستوياتي الاداره
الامريكيه
كيف ينظر الليبيون بدورهم الى زياره شخصيه
كا سيد ويليامبرز الى ليبيا في هذا الوقت
هو الحقيقه
الزياره مدير
ربما ارسلت رسائل سلبيه الى قطاعه لا باس
به من المراقبين والمتابعين الليبيين هذا
يعني بالنسبه لهم ان الملف
الليبي اصبح
امنيا مخابراتيا بامتياز
وان الطبيعه العلنيه للزياره
والاجراءات البروتيكليه التي اتخذت
وكانها تقول لليبيين بان واشنطن تتعامل
معكم في كل القضايا ليس فقط ما ذكرها
الضيف من واشنطن روسيا والمجموعات
الارهابيه المتجدده بل في كل الملفات قناه
التعامل معها من قبل واشنطن عبر هذا
الجهاز وهذا المسؤول للامني الكبير وانا
اعتقد بان الاشارات ربما ليست ايجابيه وان
القلق هو سيد الموقف في النظر الى التحول
في اداره امريكا للملف الليبي طيب وهنا
همم السيد جون الثاني افهم منك اكثر في
حديثنا عن همم ما حمله من اجنده همم سيد
همم ويليامبرز عند ذهابه ولقائه همم في ان
كان في بنغازي بحفتر او في طرابلس اا
ولقائه بالبيبه ما الذي حمله في هذه
الزياره
[موسيقى]
كان دبلوماسيه
لثلاثه عقود وكان سفيرا لدى هذا عن عدد من
في ذلك روسيا اذا هو مخول في بحث في
تشكيله واسعه من القضايا حسب وجهه نظري
انه صوت وفاعل اضافي وليس تعويضا عن
السفير الذي لم يحضر الاجتماع الذي قد
يتعامل مع الامور
بدقائقها اليوميه طبعا هو مبعوث على اعلى
المستويات وهو عامل مع الخارجيه وعمل مع
بعضنا عندما كان نائبا للرئيس وعمل مع
الرئيس اوباما وعمل مع مع مكتب الامن
القومي طبعا وكانه مديرا للسي اي اي لديه
واجبات محدده تتعلق بمكافحه الارهاب نحن
في هذه اللحظه عندما تكون النشاطات
الروسيه
وتقتل الناس في اوكرانيا وتسبب بمشاكل
روسيا ايضا تدخل القاره الافريقيه بطريقه
ممهجه تستخدم
الحيز الذي سيطر عليه في ليبيا للتدخل في
افريقيا ما وراء الصحراء لهذا السبب السيد
الاول لك ولكن السؤال الان هو لماذا اختار
السيد دبي وسيد حفتر دون غيرهما في ساحه
توجد فيها الكثير من القيادات التي تتنازع
على همم صداره القياده وتتنازع الشرعيه
صور
على معطياتي المهمه التي اكل بها وهي ما
تزال
قائد السريه
لها علاقه بمكافحه الارهاب
وايضا تتعلق بحقيقه ان الولايات المتحده
تعترف بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
ربما ربما سيسعى الى نايل لدعم من قوات
حفتر طبعا سيكون من الاسهل علينا ان نجيب
اذا كانت حقائق كنا نحن نخمن فقط
في اسطنبول برايك يعني تعدد الواجهات همم
للمؤسسات التي تقدم نفسها على انها صاحبه
السياده والشرعيه في همم ليبيا كثيره وانت
ادرى بها لماذا جرح اختيار الحديث مع سيد
دبي وحفتر دون غيرهما
حقيقه وسوء الجوهري يعني ان قلنا بان
رئيس او مدير المخابرات الامريكيه مبعوث
بصلاحيات اكبر من مجرد العمل الامني
والمخابرات بل حتى التدخل في الدبلوماسيه
والعلاقات السياسيه مع ليبيا فلماذا لم
يتجه الى رئيس مجلس النواب او يتجه رئيس
مجلس الرئاسي السيد المسيحي او الى رئيس
المجلس الاعلى الدوله
وال رئيس مجلس النواب رئيس مجلس الدوله
معنيان اليوم اليوم همم بوضع الاساس
الدستوري القائد الدستوريه وقوانين
الانتخابات همم اللي هي تعتبر الملف الاهم
بالنسبه الامريكان فيما يتعلق بالعمليه
السياسيه الليبيه تخطى هؤلاء جميعا ذهب
الى دبيبه والى حفتنه في رايي الشخصي لانه
الرؤيه لدى الامريكان بان هذه الاجسام
ربما كانت سبب في تعطيل المسار السياسي
وان الاتجاه الى الاطراف النا التي لديها
سلطه السياسه وسلطه المال وسلطه القوه
الامنيه ربما يسهل اداره الملف الامني او
الليبي بشكل ايسر هناك بعد اخر ان ربما من
بين الملف الذي جاء به مدير المخابرات
الامريكيه قضايا متعلقه بسلطه التنفيذ
بمعنى مسائل تحتاج الى قرار امني سريع
واجراءات امنيه سريعه لا يملكها رئيس مجلس
النواب ولا رئيس مجلس على الدوله ولا رئيس
المجلس الرئاسي وهي
يعني كم ذكر ضيفك هناك موضوع المجموعات
المتشدده هناك ملف روسيا وانا رايي الشخصي
ملف مهم جدا اليوم مصادر اوروبيه مطلعه
تتحدث عن تصعيد امريكي
وقرارات وسياسات واجراءات متعلقه بملاحقه
الشركات الامنيه الروسيه العامله خارج
ساحه الصراع مع اوكرانيا ليبيا في مقدمه
هذه الساحات فاذن ربما الملف الروسي
والابرز مجموعه المتشدده المصالح
الامريكيه التي تمثلها الشركات الامريكيه
العامله في قطاع النفق كامل ولكن دون
راتبيه محدده تبدا بالخطر الروسي
فالمجموعات المتشدده فالمصالح التي تمثلها
الشركات النفطيه وسال عن هذه التراتبيه
ضيفنا سيدك كيف ترتب واشنطن
اولاوياتها بالنسبه لما تريده من لي من
خلال هذه الزياره التي يقوم بها اا سيد او
قام بها السيد برز نظرا الى هذه الساحه
التي همم توجد فيها مثلا ساحه الدوليه
توجد فيها تعقيدات سوق الطاقه نتيجه الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا هناك ايضا ملف وجود
فاكنار على الاراضي
الليبيه اضافه الروسي في منطقه الساحل
والصحراء وايضا الوجود الصيني والمزيد من
التدخل الصيني في المنطقه ما هي الاولويه
رشا
هي اولويه طبعا اذا ما اخذنا
الاعتبار
سلوكها المريع في حربها في محاوله السيطره
على اوكرانيا وشعبها
لا بد ان تكون له اهداف
التحديث او ليطلب طلبا ما او كلاهما معا
حسب تخزينه هو لم يلتقي باطراف اخرى في
ليبيا لانه لا يعتبرها لها علاقه
بالقضايا الاساسيه التي ارادها هو التركيز
عليها ربما هناك
محاوله لطلب تسليم اشخاص ما يتعلق بقضيه
لكربه ربما هناك امور ايضا كما قلنا تتعلق
بروسيا
اعتقاد الراسخ انه يسعى لنوع من التعاون
في مجال
الارتبك انا عندما كنت مبعوثا خاصه كان
هدفنا الاساس هو التخلص من سيطره تنظيم
الدوله على المناطق التي كان يسيطر عليها
وما كان يعاملوا
الشعب الليبي معامله سيئه وانا
ذهبت الى كل فرد الافراد مجلس الدوله
وطالبتنا ان نقول هل تساعدوننا في هذه
القضيه طبعا ضروره
طبعا
حتى رئيس الوزراء شخصيا لم لم يكن هناك
الجميع موافق على اعطاء الموافقه على
الطرحاتنا لكن قضيه تنظيم الدوله طبعا انا
لما اتحدث الى تشكيله واسعه من الليبيين
حول هذا الامر تكلمت مع من لهم سلطه
السياسيه وقدره وهذا بالطبع ما يفعله
السيد بانز ايضا
امكانيه ان تتقاطع مصالح
الطرف الامريكي مع مصالح كل من طرابلس
وبنغازي في هذه الاجودات والاهداف المعينه
التي يمكن ان تطلبها واشنطن من بنغازي
وطرابلس
الطرفين السيد بيبو وسيد حفتر يشعران
كونهما كانوا محل اختيار لدار الامريكيه
في ان يزورهم المبعوث الامريكي
بهذه الثقل وهذا الوسم همم هذا يرسل لهم
رسائل واضحه بانهما معنيان مباشره
بالتعاون مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في الملفات المهمه خصوصا وان كل منهما
يواجه تحديات في اداره المرحله السياسيه
والمصادر السياسيه الراهن حفتر يتخوف من
الاقصاب بسبب يعني
جنسيته الامريكيه وقصه انه عسكري لا يحق
له الترشح للانتخابات
تحديدا همم تعهد بالادخل بالانتخابات فان
يتحصل على هذا هذا
التوجيه الامريكي والاهتمام الامريكي يعني
لهما الكثير في رايي في هذه المرحله
الحساسه الى اي درجه يمكن ان يمضي هذا
التعاون هذا كما ذكر ضيفك ما يعني مرتبط
بالاجنده الامريكيه همم حيل المساله
الليبيه خلال الايام الاسابيع والاشهر
القليله القادمه
هو ايضا محل قلق ايضا ومخاوف من قبل
المجتمع الدولي المبعوث الاممي تحديدا الا
ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي قال ان المصالحه في
ليبيا لن تكتمل الا بحكومه موحده ونظام
اقتصادي واجتماعي وسياسي موحد واكد باتيلي
في تصريحات الوسائل الاعلام الليبيه محليه
على ان الامم المتحده تدعم المصالحه
الوطنيه بوصفها مشروعا مهما وخطوه جيده
نحو تاسيس ليبيا واضاف باتيلي ان على كل
قائد او مواطن تحمل مسؤولياته للتواصل الى
حلول والا فان ليبيا ستنقسم الى اشلاء حسب
التعبيره
سيد جونس ما المساهمه التي يمكن ان تقدمها
واشنطن لتجاوز هذه الازمه خاصه بان الوضع
في ليبيا بلغ مرحله الخطوره
بالتشظ بنظرا لمقالته الامم المتحده
والرسنوات عديده الان وافقت وشجعت على
فكره ان الشعب الليبي ينبغي ان يكون هو
نفسه ولا احد غيره يختار حكومته بطرق
الديمقراطيه ولا يصعب عن طريق السيطره
العسكريه
واخر مره صوت فيها شعبي الشعب اللي كان في
يونيون 2014 ومره وقت طويل منذ ذلك الوقت
لهذا السبب عمليه الانتقام يجب ان تلقى
قبولا على نطاق واسع وصولا الى حكومه لا
تقصي احدا هذه من اهداف السياسات
المتحده لا تفضل مرشحا دون الاخار هذا امر
مسروق الى الشعب اللي
وهذا ما تقوله واشنطن منذ مده وتشجع
البلدان الاخرى على ان تتخذ نفس المسار
وصولا الى حكومه واستقر في ليبيا توفره
فرص الاستقرار والازدهار الاقتصادي
الشعبها وايضا الذين سيعترضون ذلك المسار
يجب ان يتعرضوا
للعقوبات والولايات المتحده تقول
الكل في ليبيا يجب ان يعمل من اجله وجودي
مصري في المركزي يتلقى كل الموارد ويكون
ويتعاملوا بشفافيه وضمن مثل هذه الاليات
يكون هناك سيطره نقديه وعلى عمله البلاد
واوضاع الاقتصاديه طبعا البلدان البلد
ينقسم الى اجزاء على اساس الجغرافيا
وغيرها لكن هل ينبغي ان يكون هناك مثلا
الجزء تنقسم البلد ينقسم الى مدن او ما
الى ذلك في النهايه يجب ان يكون هناك
سياسه توفر محفزات اقتصاديه تتيح للبلد
درمته ان يتحرك وهذا من شانه ان يحقق
الكثير ليس لليبيا فقط بل القاره
الافريقيه ولمنطقه البحر المتوسط بل
والعالم ايضا
في زياره
ويليامبرز اليها مشروع
سياسي لطرحه
اتمنى ذلك واشنطن كانت متاخره جدا وبعيده
عن التاثير الفعلي النافذ على المسار
السياسي ومحاوله احتواء النزاع الداخلي
والاطراف الاقليميه وحتى الدوليه التي
تدخلت سلبا على الملف الليبي انا اعتقد
باننا
بامكان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عبر
هذا التطور الحديث وتكليف مدير الجهاز
المخابرات الامريكي
لقياده الملف الليبي ان تؤثر ايجابا على
المسار السياسي القادمه
اعتقد بان دبيبه وحفتر هما الوحدان
القادران على عرقله هذا المصر لا توجد
كتله اخرى قادره على العقبه المسار
السياسي والوصول الى موعد قريب للانتخابات
الا هذين شخصين بنفودهما السياسي الامني
المالي ان مارست واشنطن عبره وكيلها اليوم
ضغطا على هذين الرجلين وزياره لهما قد
تكون هذه الدلاله الايجابيه ان مارست
واشنطن عبر وكيلها الضغط على هؤلاء الا
يعرقل المسار الانتقام باعتبار انهما قد
يستبعد من الانتخابي او او استمرار او
استمرارهم كقائد عام جيوش او رئيس حكومه
ان ما صدقتا على هذين ان لا يعرف الى
المصاري السياسيه اعتقد بينه سيقع التطور
مهم جدا في الازمه الليبيه ابغى نصيب الى
توافق وانفراج السيد جونسون بختصار هل ترى
ان لدى واشنطن النيه في ممارسه هذا الدور
السياسي باختصار
انا المره ان لا يبالغ في في
قدره اي اي طرف في تحقيق مصيري ومستقبل
ليبيا حقيقه اي انخراط من جانب الاداره
الامريكيه هو امر جيد لفتره طويله كان
سياستنا ترمي الى ترك الليبيين يحققونا
طموحاتهم من خلال انتخابات لكن
لا يقل كفاءه عن اي دبلوماسيه اخر واي ام
دبلوماسين انتجته الولايات المتحده منذ
عقود من الزمن وجودهم مهم وربما
المبعوث الامريكي السابق لا ليبيا ومن
اسطنبول
مدير المركز الليبي للبحوث والتنميه شكرا
لكما
الى هناك تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]